[Music]
today's question comes from jason in
texas jason writes i've been a huge fan
for 20 years but have not been able to
implement any of your strategies because
just take a pause right there
my wife thinks tithing and the rest of
your methods are too restrictive she
stopped going to church a long time ago
and refuses to forgive me for things
that happened in our past
the ministers that i've consulted with
say she has emotionally and spiritually
abandoned me years ago
oh man my 18 year old watches your
videos and loves them she keeps asking
why didn't you and mom do all this stuff
it seems to work really well
i'm trying to explain why but don't want
to throw her mom under the bus
is there a way a 52 year old can start
over in life and help a daughter be a
calm all she can be
oh
yes
as our i do it all the time yeah all the
time
um
i don't want to minimize jason i don't
minimize your pain here's what your
daughter really needs
um to quote our friend jocko
she needs you to take ownership
uh you look back over your life and it's
because your wife did this your wife
didn't do that it's because of this
what she needs you to say is i didn't
i made some choices along the way
and here's where i find myself and
here's what i'm going to do
with these next steps and here's what
you can do too
and there's something about that
ownership that's really powerful
so
it sounds like there's a
a chasm
in this relationship is this due for
an ultimatum like you go see a marriage
counselor um and you say
uh i'm gonna go see a counselor and if
we can't begin to get on the same page
and resolve some of these things then
we're gonna call this
um it it
the way it writes is there a way to
start over i was just assuming that
they've
called it yeah they've called it so
it sounds like he has the ministers have
given him permission
is in his mind right but i don't think
he's looked at her and said this is done
it's time for me to move it's um unless
we can heal right this is done that's
right um
just zero chance of healing or
yeah i mean if somebody if your
spouse left you emotionally and
spiritually and physically years and
years ago
then yeah these kids have grown up in a
home and that's their picture of what
love looks like that's their picture of
what marriage and partnership and
communication and connection looks like
and so healing starts with
um
i didn't i should have had a hard
conversation a long long time ago and i
didn't and this is the law
so basically they've been divorced they
just need to actually formalize it they
they've been divorced for a long time
and they just need to formalize they've
modeled modeled what that looks like to
their kids and so it starts with
ownership here's some choices i didn't
make right a long long time ago
um and here's the more importantly or as
importantly as here's what i'm going to
start doing now and i'd love you to join
me
and i think i think it's that
complicated and that hard and that
simple
yeah when we went through bankruptcy and
lost everything it
um terrorized me and traumatized sharon
um and so
that's a thing i did that she had to
forgive me for in a sense because i
basically you know she i always laugh
and say she thought she married sir
galahad turns out it was goober but um
but that's you know the the truth is she
was left
um
with situation but i was not going on
nor but i
there's a period of time that
we can uh recognize the terror that she
felt the trauma from having little kids
and no money in the water got turned off
because her husband's a buffoon right
okay granted but five years later we're
not still talking about that then she's
choosing to carry that stuff around and
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna be at the
other end of that weapon
i didn't find him right once somebody
says i'm staying so dude 20 years ago
you did something you know after four
years of that
everything after four years is your
fault
if you choose to carry that thing around
no you know he put he accepted
the paralyzation of the household for 16
years longer than he should have that's
right that's right he should have dealt
with her that's right a long long time
ago lack of healing that's right and it
was not that she didn't have a
valid reason for being pissed i don't
know what he did right but i know what i
did i lost everything it was my fault
sharon had no idea what was going on it
wasn't her fault i didn't hide it from
her i just didn't ask her right
and she didn't know and so she's left
feeling uh you know
uh like you're driving down the road
in the middle of the night and you hit a
patch of ice and the car starts spinning
yeah that's again you know you're gonna
hit something you just don't know what
or when and you know and that's where
she was for a year and a half period of
time as we went down the the
toilet financially and the round and
around we go you know and so
yeah granted and today even um you know
we've got
checks and balances in our relationship
in place so that um she's not left
feeling like i'm somehow out of control
again
because because that little seizure that
was 30 years ago that's right and uh how
old was rachel when all this happened
born baby she's a baby so when i think
about my friend rachel we've talked
about this when she has a uh emergency
fund for her emergency fund those seeds
were planted in
money could be scarce so money's a thing
right and that's those are long ago
right so she's sell attention from her
mom sit with your daughter and have that
conversation right here jason take
ownership brother
yeah time past time to take ownership
this is the ramsey show